une naissance royale
une vie épiée par les médias du monde
Charles 4 ans témoin privilégié du
couronnement de sa mère ne se doute pas
des embûches qu'il devra surmonter
durant les 70 prochaines années il a été
un enfant qui n'a pas été aimé à la
mesure de ce qu'il attendait
quand Elisabeth II et Philippe
reviennent de 6 mois de tourner du
commonwell les retrouvailles avec leur
fils se limitent à une accolade froide
et distante elle était reine à plein
temps et meurt par intermittence
charlira à l'école comme les autres
enfants ou presque c'est un élève moyen
sans plus il a été un peu ostracisé par
certains de ses camarades il a également
été le victime de brimades son père mise
sur une éducation à la dure il envoie
son fils au pensionnat écossais de
Gordon Stone une épreuve traumatique
pour l'adolescent
il a subi en silence beaucoup de
difficultés alors ça l'a guéri en même
temps ça l'a rendu peut-être plus fort
d'une certaine manière
après une jeunesse tourmentée le prince
déploie ses ailes
à l'université de Cambridge il pratique
le polo ce passionne de plein air il
joue au théâtre où il laisse libre cours
à sa créativité
il affirme sa propre personnalité mais
le choix de l'élu de son cœur sera
néanmoins dicté par son statut
d'héritier au trône
un mariage sublime
de leur union
et Harry les Britanniques tombent en
amour avec les lits Diana
de la chance mais la lune de miel se
termine brusquement
l'infidélité du prince avec son amour de
jeunesse Camille la Parker bows choque
les Britanniques voilà comment le prince
Charles est devenu la personnalité la
plus un populaire de la famille royale
Charles le mal aimé de sa nation les
histoires familiales le font une fois de
plus souffrir ça lui a fait mal parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui est très
sensible et qui a besoin d'être aimé et
qui toute sa vie aussi a dû cacher cette
cette terrible faiblesse pour un prince
ce besoin d'être aimé Buckingham lance
une campagne de relations publiques pour
réhab et celle pour qui il a jeté son
dévolu les relations familiales ou avec
son Expos sont les plus actuels ont
peut-être parfois occulté le personnage
qu'il est la personnalité qu'il est et
les combats qu'il a menaient Charles
millet en faveur de la protection de
l'environnement il s'implique avec
Kamila dans des œuvres caritatives
les tourtereaux se marient finalement en
que la force du roi Charles c'est sa
résilience c'est-à-dire que quand il a
le sentiment de toucher le fond il y a
une force en lui qui le fait remonter à
la surface et il arrive à surmonter les
pires situations Charles sort finalement
de l'ombre de sa mère à 74 ans fait prêt
pour occuper le rôle qui lui était
prédestiné
ici Jean-Philippe news Radio-Canada
Montréal